احنا مشاهدينا من العراق والاردن سالنا
الناس متى يصبح حزم المعلم على طلابه مؤذي
نفسيا خلينا نشوف سؤال
هو واجب المعلم بدوره انه يكون منصح
ما نتعرض لازم من خلاله لا العنف جسدي ولا
العنف معنوي اكو طرق هلا هوايه موضوع
التدريس لازم تتبع هاي الطرق لما تتجاوز
مثلا يصير في اساءه لفظيه اساءه جسديه هنا
يعني يكون يتجاوز حده
يعني كنا نخاف على المعلم مالنا قاعد
بالقهوه احنا نتجنب الطريق الثاني حين
يقفل عن تاثير الكلمات التي يقولها نوعيه
الكلمات التي يقولها على النشئ الجديد او
الاطفال اللي او الاعمار المبكره يعني
انه مهمه الطالب المفروض المعلم انه ما
ينزل المستوى الطالب
مؤذي لما الحزم يبطل يصب في مصلحه الطالب
لما ياثر على نفسيه الطالب على ثقه الطالب
في نفسه على يعني كيف بعبر الطالب عن نفسه
بين زملائه في المدرسه
يعني لازم يكون نوعا ما بتعرف شو اللي هي
التوازن او اللي هو الوسطيه في التعامل مع
الامور لا يكون كثير شد على الطلاب ولا
يكون كثير مرخي مع الطلاب لازم يكون في
اولا في بين الاستاذ والطفل احترام متبادل
مبدئيا يعني احترام المتبادل عشان ما يكون
الحزم بزياده على الطالب يعني طول ما
الطفل ضمن الحدود طول ما الاستاذ الامور
بينهم بتكون طبيعيه لكن عندما يعني بيكون
الطفل نص نص طبعا بده يكون الاستاذ الحزم
عليه اكثر يعني بس طبعا ضمن الحدود بحزمه
المعلم على الطالب يعني بكون هو عباره عن
تنبيه بالكلام الشفوي
ويكون يعني الضرب طبعا مش مسموح يعني بكون
مؤذي للطفل نفسه خصوصا بالاعمار الصغيره
فبكون عباره عن تنبيه شفوي لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات